we are all trapped inside our own heads
and our beliefs and our understandings
about the world are limited by that
perspective which means we tell
ourselves stories right so here we are
in this infinite data source there's an
infinite number of things that we could
think about but we edit and delete we
choose what to think about what to pay
attention to we make up a story to make
sense of what's going on and we all get
it wrong because we're all trying to
navigate with our own skewed compasses
and we all have our own baggage but the
stories themselves are utterly
convincing and we all do this and a lot
of the stories that we live by aren't
even our own the first ones we inherit
at a young age from our parents who of
course have their own skewed beliefs
their own frustrations their own unlived
lives and for better or worse we take
all that on board and then we go out
into the world thinking maybe we have to
be successful to be loved or that we
always have to put other people's needs
first
all that we have some big terrible
secret we couldn't possibly tell people
and it's just fiction it's just stories
and we'd worry a lot less about what
other people think of us if we realized
how seldom they do
so I I I feel that magic is a great
analogy for how we edit reality and form
a story and then mistake that story for
the truth
and I've had a 20-year career in the UK
staging big psychological experiments on
TV and now that's on Netflix
I also have a stage show I've got my
first Broadway show actually coming up
called secret just throwing that out
there no pressure there should be this
year ah and I try to do something new
with mintues and mentalism which is the
dubious art of getting inside your head
so there was a heyday for this kind of
stage mind-reading which was the 1930s
that's why I'm dressed like this my most
untied like garb and there was an act
and act known as the Oracle act and in
the Oracle Act members of the audience
as I know you have done would write down
secret questions the sort of question
you might ask a psychic seal that
question into an envelope and on the
outside of the envelope they would write
their initials and then roughly where
they're sat in the audience and then the
Oracle the mind reader would take an
envelope one at a time you wouldn't open
it but he would attempt to divine what
question was sealed inside and if he got
that right he would try and answer the
question for the person - and the act
spread like wildfire it's a testament I
think to the seductive appeal of some
powerful figure offering you easy simple
answers to life's complex and subtle
questions and anxieties so thank you all
of you that wrote questions I haven't
seen these I know somebody's guarding
them someone's collected them up thank
you so much thank you sir I will take
those now thank you all of you that did
this I should say probably a couple of
things before I start in absolute
honesty first of all I can't see through
these envelopes they are sealed they are
thicker black envelopes you'll know if
you wrote one I can't see through them
secondly importantly I don't know any of
you and
vd is playing along that's not what this
is thirdly I don't believe for a second
that I have any special psychological
gifts let alone any psychic ones so
let's begin nope
ok this oh nice
okay this one's interest there's a
couple here I can start with maybe this
one this one's interesting because the
writing undulates there's a sort of an
up-and-down thing which normally not
always normally means that the person
doesn't know the answer to the question
themselves so it's normally a question
about the future right that sort of
suggests uncertainty so I'd say it's an
a lady age wise it's a little difficult
to tell from this minimal handwriting
but I'd expect maybe maybe 30s maybe 40s
but let's find out it says I'm a I'm a
question about the future it says j-n
Center so it's gonna be somebody in
there's big central section here if you
think this is you if you wrote one could
you make a fast it's a bit difficult for
me to see in the center hi give us a
wave so Jay Jane Jessica yes which one
Jessica Jessica thank you it's just a
guest at a murmur of approval think it's
um I'll take it
alright so Jessica I won't ask your age
but is it a question essentially about
the future mm-hmm yes yes yes okay all
right so what are we asked what does
Jessica ask about the future so am i
okay with late thirties early forties
I'm gonna have to say it I'm taking it
okay okay so it's important because we
ask different questions depending how
old we are I think with you this is
going to be just just say just say I'll
take it again just say those words I'll
take it Virginia from Virginia yes I am
yeah
so I think this is a lady I think this
is a lady who wants to leave Virginia I
I think you're looking at plans or it's
whether or not things are going to come
together to get up and that's just show
me show me your hands other side so I
can see fingernails okay I think you I
think it's I think you have a farm and
it's whether or not you're gonna sell
your farm and get out of Virginia
is this right
all right thank you it's a great
question it's a what what was the actual
question what was what did you put will
they sell the farm in Virginia will you
sell it up all right so look it's a
great question if you are a pretending
to be psychic because it's about the
future which means I can give you a yes
or no on this it means nothing you have
no way of verifying it and the dangerous
thing to do really if I say yes I know
it'll just stick in the back of your
mind and it can't not start to affect
you know decisions you make so a
dangerous thing to do however yes I
think you will sell the farm because I
think you're the sort of person that in
the nicest way will get what you want I
think I think when there's things you
want you tend to focus on them at the
expense of other things that you know
you probably should be focusing on more
would you agree educated you know you
spend a few years and still say yes
again the word yes quickly yes
no no California Berkeley is a bit of a
guess but I went to Berkeley I said yeah
so listen it's a yes oh and you've been
to India recently as well there's just a
tiny tiny little thing going on there
yes no yes yes yes for me I just don't
want to say it like it's written in the
stars because it isn't and you need to
take responsibility for it would you
accept that hasn't answered your
question though yes yes thank you
a aah also in the center aah would be a
man little older maybe late forties I
would say for this aah Center stand up
for me if you think this is you aah hi
it's got a microphone to the sky quick
as you can on the camera wood is amazing
oh look at that freeze don't move don't
move keep absolutely still hmm are you
standing where I I am standing in my
best short okay all right now you've
okay you've changed that there was just
something you did as you as you got up
yes or no have you put something on here
you're not doing it now but you did it
as you stood up to do with your left
either your left leg or your left foot
yes or no just yes or no yes yes all
right he was giving us a nice clear
signal as you stood up all right I'll
try to be quick on this put your weight
on your left hand side and say yes for
me yes take your hand out of that pocket
but your weight on the other side change
hands with the mic and say yes again yes
you have
you've got your you have a dislocation
in the big toe on your left-hand side
yes thank you so much right good luck
take a seat take a seat all right can I
get the mic if I'm going to change
microphone for this guy grab a mic up
thank you um thank you so much that
would be great there I'm gonna change
mic because hopefully you can now still
hear me as I'm going to blindfold myself
and I'm doing this now so that don't so
I don't have the clues as you stand up I
can't see where you put your hands I
can't see how you respond to what I'm
saying can't see what the people next
you were doing either if they know the
answers of the question that's always
very helpful um I won't have those
advantages but strangely this frees me
up and I want this to free you up as
well so if you didn't write a question
but you wish that you had done you can
still take part the point of writing the
question is only that it just kind of
gets a nice clear succinct wording in
your head so if you can do that anyway
if you can just find a question in your
head make it clear and succinct just
send it to me and I'll try to do this
now with
anything written down so just start to
form questions but send me your name as
well that's important my name is
whatever that last guy was sorry and you
know what's strange about my feet or
whatever the question was so named and
and question there is somebody already
I'm guessing you're quite near the phone
because your name is quite clear feels
like you're in the center at the front
okay let me just Alan
feels like this an Alan and you neither
Friday York what I'm you're gonna be
quite near the front vaguely central I
think there's like it's coming from
right there it was like a man maybe six
early sixties something like that yes
okay so you got a Mike great thank you
it's gonna my to this guide Alan just
just say stop when I get you so that I
know where you are where to face start
you Capricorn yes so Alan has something
in his head now did you hear it hear the
reserve and his voice it's gonna be
something really tricky I think with you
I just say yes again for me yes it's
going to be either no it's not as a part
is so it's access it's part it's a
password or access to something you've
had if you've got something just yes or
no with the password in your head yes I
could computer password that sort of
thing yes on this one let me if I get
this right they're all going to know
what it is and millions of people
potentially what you will change it
won't you of course alright okay do you
say of course again of course all right
what is it if it's a word I've actually
it's a word I just see the password
written in front of you big clear block
capital letters and as you look at it
think for me of a letter somewhere in
the middle don't say it out loud just
get a letter in your head that somewhere
in the middle if you got one yeah okay
stick with that for me yeah you changed
your huh okay you changed your mind
though I think you settled on a I think
that's a be yes no I didn't then it's an
I correct yeah
you had a B yes yes yeah he changed his
mind change his mind okay so see it
written there
let me just alright just keep saying it
yourself in your head it get it oh you
play drums don't you I do yeah just get
that out of here get that out of here
just pretend as though there's nothing
for them my job is to sell you a story
right I try and do this to all of you to
get you to pay attention to one thing
that I want you to find important ignore
other things that I want you to ignore
and then join up those narrative dots to
tell yourself a certain story about what
I'm doing and this only works because we
are story forming creatures which means
we do this every day we go out into this
complex and subtle world full of complex
and subtle people like you and me Alan
and we reduce them to these neat
characters that fit whatever story were
telling ourselves and we say she's
insecure he's arrogant they can't be
trusted and these are just stories like
the story that I couldn't somehow read
your mind you're thinking of selling
your company as well aren't you at the
moment correct what you something to do
which is something to do with skin
skincare or something like this yes and
I think the reason why I love doing this
is that it reminds me at least to try
and be more alive and alert to the
complexity and the subtlety of what's
real that there's always other stuff
going on that we don't know about and it
means we can get less stuck we can be
kinder to people because we can
recognize there's always fear behind
their stress so we don't need to meet it
as defensively and we can start to see
the stories for what they are and
recognize that life isn't all about us
Oh
your password where are you where are
you where is right here stand up for me
your password is Harry boy AR IBO why is
that right that's correct and thank you
so much thank you very much and anything
[Applause]